jørgen lhasa Jaguar erection a positive
you know tompa dogs xeo liqueur atari
quality ha exactly at the Paris climate
conference in December 2015 195
countries agreed to the world's first
Universal action plan to tackle climate
change by limiting global warming to
well below 2 degrees Celsius this
historic achievement was just the
beginning
now every country must turn their
promises into action
human activities such as burning fossil
fuels livestock farming and
deforestation cause global temperatures
to surge rising sea levels will put
coasts and low-lying islands at risk
severe droughts and super storms will
become more frequent and one in six of
Earth's species will be threatened this
is why in Paris countries committed to
tackle climate change by reducing
greenhouse gas emissions and taking
measures to adapt to the unavoidable
impacts of climate change this will
require a worldwide economic
transformation unlocking the potential
of renewables making agriculture more
sustainable decarbonizing transport and
redesigning the electricity market
this transition will bring new
opportunities to industries investors
and innovative companies and the more a
country does the more its citizens will
benefit through job creation smarter
products cleaner air and more secure
energy supplies making this happen will
be a challenge we all have a role to
play more than ten thousand companies
investors regions cities and civil
society organizations are already taking
action across the globe but climate
change related events are already
happening more frequently all countries
are affected and face the task of
building up their resilience to
environmental changes one thing is
certain international cooperation is key
to reach a global climate solution
developed countries have committed to
helping others with technology
strengthening institutions and also
finance
other countries including emerging
economies are also increasingly
providing support to the most vulnerable
nations the European Union is already
putting its Paris commitment into action
and will reduce its emissions by at
least 40 percent by 2030 since 1990 the
EU has already reduced its emissions by
almost a quarter while at the same time
growing its economy by almost 50 percent
the Paris agreement gives us a global
action plan to fight climate change by
working together we can build a safer
and more sustainable world for us all
and for future generations
you